smile and wave one two three South East
Asian leaders gather for their family
photo at the start of the asean summit
in Phnom Penh warm smiles and handshakes
as they're greeted by their host
Cambodian prime minister Hansen but in
his opening address he noted that the
war in Ukraine and Rising inflation are
a serious challenge for the region
we are now at the most uncertain
juncture the lives of millions in our
region depend on our wisdom and farsight
our right decisions and policies and our
realistic approach to address the
Strategic challenges we all face
as the leaders got down to business
there was one notable absentee while
myanmar's flag was still flying its
ruling generals were not invited after a
year of pressure they refused to keep to
asean's five-point peace plan within
asean some like Thailand are known to
favor a policy of appeasement others
would like to take a tougher line
as the afternoon's meetings broke up it
was clear that no consensus had been
reached nonetheless Indonesia's
president left no doubt that more must
be done Indonesia is deeply
disappointed
the situation in Myanmar is worsening
no significant progress on the
implementation of Five Point consensus
and then no commitment
of Junta to implement Five Point
consensus
we must not allow
situation in Myanmar to Define asean
on the other side of the globe U.S
President Joe Biden was setting off on a
journey that will bring him to Cambodia
on Saturday that'll shift the focus in
Phnom Penh to the global economic issues
that are having an impact across the
region
it's no surprise that asean's leaders
have been unable to decide how to
proceed with Myanmar but it's also clear
that some of those leaders are losing
patience and that the Myanmar dilemma is
creating deep divisions within the
association Tony Chang Al Jazeera Phnom
Penh